-What's up?
-What's up, Seth?
-Good to see you guys.
-Hi.
-You are bundled up,
Michael Che.
-Yeah, man.
I'm not used to this weather.
-Really?
-I'm from the Island.
[ Laughter ]
Manhattan Island.
-Yeah.
-You guys are actually
both from the islands.
You're from
the island of Manhattan.
-That's right.
-And you're from
the island of Staten.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Sounds just as tropical, right?
-Yeah.
Well, they --
Now JetBlue goes direct
to Staten Island, so...
-JetBlue has ferry service now.
I was gonna come out and wear --
I was gonna wear
a Hawaiian shirt,
but he talked me out of it.
-Really?
-And say that I was more
dressing for the job I wanted.
-Oh, gotcha.
-Versus this, but then he --
-And the job you wanted
is "Magnum P.I."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Why not?
-What job do I want? Panhandler?
[ Laughter ]
I should be selling batteries
on a D train.
-I was so --
You guys had a month off,
which is unheard of
in my 10 years, which is --
-No, we never left.
-You had a month off.
Did you enjoy yourselves?
-Uh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
You didn't go anywhere.
-Yeah, I had to see
a lot of family.
That wasn't fun.
-Really?
-Yeah, 'cause, you know,
they just tell me
who else they think is funny.
-Oh, really?
I know -- I know
what you're talking about.
-Yeah, that's not fun to hear.
-Yeah.
Do you think that happens
with athletes, like when --
-"You know who's fast?"
and stuff like that.
-Yeah.
Or like Eli Manning at, like,
Thanksgiving dinner, someone's
like, "You know who's great?
Tom Brady."
Like, do you think he --
[ Light laughter ]
-100%.
-You think 100%.
-I mean, based on your own --
don't you think 100%?
Based on knowing any family.
-I think they must.
-You know who says that to him
is Peyton Manning.
-Peyton does, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
As a super burn.
I had a lovely time.
I got to come back
and host this year.
It was so fun
to be back with you guys.
-Yeah, it was great.
-Got to come back
on the "Update" desk,
which was for me the highlight.
I'm not gonna call it
a low light, but it was not --
in the end, did not turn out
to be a highlight.
You wrote a sketch for me.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-I should point out,
it was not new business.
-No, I wrote it
probably about 12 years ago.
-And you resubmitted it
for me, because --
-And I thought,
"Only you could do this sketch."
-Well, I -- the actor you
originally wrote it for
is someone that I think
a lot of people mistake me for,
and so it made sense that you
would try it again with me.
-Well, originally,
it was Taylor Lautner.
[ Laughter ]
So I was like, "Who else is in
sort of the 'Twilight' space?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Same fan base.
-You read
as a classic "Twilight."
-And I was there for that,
so I knew,
"Oh, Jost submitted
a Taylor Lautner sketch for me."
-Yeah.
So, you're welcome.
-Do you want to explain
the premise of Manny Manimal?
-Well, should we --
-Manny Manimal.
-Sure.
His name was Manny something.
He worked
at the radioactive lab
where, like, Spider-Man
had been bitten by a spider.
-Yeah, the radioactive spider.
-So, this guy,
after he was bitten
by the radioactive spider,
he was also bitten
by a radioactive raccoon,
a starfish...
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
-...a pelican...
-Yep.
-...a couple snakes...
-I think there were like
three squirrels?
-And then he died, and a gorilla
had sex with his dead body.
-Yes.
[ Audience groans ]
-Then brought him --
-And then he was revived
by a radioactive parrot.
He was given CPR.
-And so, unlike Spider-Man --
-This isn't a real guy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, don't worry.
-They're like, "Aww."
[ Laughter ]
-But anyways,
then he is a superhero.
He was Manny Manimal,
the man of many animals.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
And you mentioned Emmy-nominated
at the beginning, right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay. Great, great.
-And also,
so his name is Manny Manimal,
the man of many animals, but
also his first name was Manny.
[ Laughter ]
Which was unnecessary.
-Very unnecessary.
-Yeah.
-I think I found that
late in the writing process.
-One of the great costumes
of all-time.
-Yes.
-There you go.
-I mean...
[ Laughter ]
-And I will say,
great opening title sequence.
-Yeah.
-Comes out in this.
Audience goes crazy.
-Yeah.
-And then what would you
describe the audience
for the rest of the sketch?
-Nightmarish?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Basically, they were so excited
to see a real superhero,
and then you basically
immediately started
coughing up blood,
because that was the premise.
-Yeah.
-That they were all --
-I had too many animal organs
in my body.
-Yeah, and no one wanted
to see 10 animals die.
-Yeah.
Again, not real.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, it bummed people out.
But it was still fun to do,
and now Lautner and I --
And we talk about it
all the time.
-Oh, definitely.
-Yeah, 'cause we hang out a lot.
-That dress audience talks about
it all the time, too.